Paco has successfully published
the first version
of his census application
on the Internet
with Google App Engine.
Users are now accessing it
and are ready to fill out
their information.
It's Paco's responsibility
to find the correct operation,
diagnose and resolve incidents
that users report,
as well as make adjustments
for even better performance
or for lower costs.
The remote administration panel
offers a series
of available online tools
that Paco will be able to use
with all these tasks.
In other words, with this panel
Paco will be able to configure,
monitor and control
different aspects
of his application
in the area of production.
To access the remote
administration panel,
Paco enters
appengine.google.com,
clicks on the link
about the identifier
for his application to access.
CONTROL BOARD OR DASHBOARD
The control board
is the starting point
and the most consulted section
of the remote admin. panel.
It will show Paco, in detail,
the amount of traffic
and overall operation
of his census application.
Immediately
underneath the charts
Paco will be able to see
the separated details
about daily consumption for
the most important resources,
available quotas and costs.
These quotas are renewed
every 24 hours.
For those resources
that are getting close
to the end
of the available quota
a red warning bar will appear
next to the related resource.
There's another section
that shows in more detail
the consumption of quotas
under the title "Quota Details."
If the application
gets close to,
or passes, any quota,
Paco must register
his credit card information
in the billing section,
as we will see further on.
While finalizing,
Paco will find a summary
with the most
accessed addresses,
and some consolidated data
related to requests,
latency and execution cycles.
The addresses with
the most errors are also listed.
LOGS
Unlike a traditional server,
where logs are accumulated
in hundreds of huge text files
that are difficult to consult,
in the remote administration
panel, Paco will have
his census application logs
indexed and available
to consult quickly at any time.
Paco will be able
to search by text,
using regular expressions,
and filter by error level
and date range.
To see the complete detail
for each request,
Paco will be able to expand them
and consult specific information
such as what navigator
the user was on,
their IP address, URL,
and the date and time
they accessed.
In the Application Settings
section,
it is also possible
to configure time duration
or the maximum size of the logs.
CONFIGURATION
AND PERFORMANCE PARAMETERS
The Application Settings section
will allow Paco to see
and change the overall aspects
of his application,
and adjust output
and performance parameters.
The type of machine
to use for the new instances
is one of them.
There are 4 options that vary
in RAM memory
and available CPU.
The better the specifications,
the higher
the hourly instance cost.
In Google App Engine,
the "Scheduler"
is responsible for routing
user requests
to active instances
with the census application,
and also to prepare
the same application
in other inactive instances,
idle instances,
for later use.
If high traffic occupies
all the available instances,
the user will experience
some latency
while new instances
are being created
or until occupied instances
become available again.
By increasing the maximum
and minimum number
of active instances,
we can control answer time,
since having
more available instances
won't be necessary
to create new ones
and thus offer an almost
immediate answer time to users.
Alternatively,
the pending latency,
Pending Latency,
determines the maximum
or minimum time that a request
waits in line before
a new instance is launched
to help with its process.
If we assign a short time,
many instances will be created,
shortening user answer time.
Keep in mind that
having more instances
means paying
a higher operation cost.
As a result, the scheduler
automatically defines
these values according
to the amount of traffic
and the application profile.
But Paco can manually
refine them
to either optimize
the application cost
or the answer times,
but not both at once.
ROLES AND PERMISSIONS
Paco needs to share
his application
with his team at work.
Nevertheless, each one
will have different tasks,
depending on their role.
Upon entering
the permissions section,
Paco will first see
the user list,
role and state.
Underneath, there is a form
to add new users, indicating
their Google email address
and role to be assigned.
The following are
the current available roles
and a summary
of the related permissions.
Viewer: Can only consult
the information
and data on the remote
administration panel,
but can not modify it.
Can download logs
through the command line.
Developer: Sees and edits
the application
on the remote
administration panel,
but can not delete it
or change roles and permissions.
They have complete access
to unfolding.
Owner: Has all available
application permissions.
Upon adding a new user,
they will receive an email
with a link
to accept the invitation.
Paco or any other
application owner
can deny access
to the other accounts
at any time by clicking
on the Remove Button
under the Remove Access column.
BILLING
Google App Engine offers
a generous free quota
with which Paco
will be able to begin
showing the census application
to his colleagues.
Once it becomes public
and receives more
and more traffic
or completes more work,
it's likely that this quota
is passed
and he needs to begin to pay.
Nevertheless, the payment model
for Google App Engine
functions as
a low demand scheme.
This means it only applies
to the resources being used.
In the Billing Status section,
Paco can assign
a weekly maximum budget
in dollars.
He can also reserve
instance hours
at discount price.
Paco will be able to assign
accounts as billing
administrators
with access to this section.
Under the Transaction History
section,
Paco will have the detailed list
with the history
of all payments,
separating the consumed use
for each resource.
In the Billing Profile
and Billing Settings sections,
Paco will be able to define
contact information,
credit cards to be used,
and other relevant
billing information.
SYSTEM STATUS
Emergency: Users report
that they can not access
the census application,
and that an error page
is being shown.
Paco wonders if it's due
to a problem
with his root code.
He checks it and doesn't
see anything wrong.
Even though Google App Engine
is one of the platforms
with the highest availability
on the market,
and it's not common,
it's possible
that it could be offline,
completely or partially.
Outside the panel,
but very important to Paco
in this situation,
is the system status board,
System Status,
where Paco will be able
to consult, in detail,
the current and past state
of each of
the platform components
Datastore, Memcash
Main, etc...
And each of the runtimes
for Python, Java and Go.
Currently, the remote
administration panel
is being moved to
the unified developers' console
by Google Cloud Platform.
On cloud.google.com/console,
Paco will be able to consult
part of the same information
he has already seen on
the remote administration panel
with a quicker
and friendlier interface.
The remote administration panel
has multiple sections,
and with each platform update
it has to grow more and more.
In this lesson, we have covered
as an introduction
the most relevant sections.
As an exercise, it's up to you
to go through the rest
of the sections on your own.
That's all for now.
Keep programming!